we are
live
hi just had a bunch of stuff outside of
Dev to take care of over the last couple
days what is wrong with my
chat hang
on me figure out what's wrong with the
chat and then we'll start on some Dev oh
there it
goes just open this
on all
right cool
um a lot of the day kind of got away
from me today doing random stuff but I
think I think we're going to do a few
research side things
today I want to see a little bit about
e3b I want to see a a little bit about a
few other
things and we will see
oops man there's been so much cool death
going on
lately in Puffer
want to keep scrolling until I see
uh where is
get very been very Spar reward
ends reward might be getting scaled
tuning check that episodic count also
works which we
did so I mean it is possible I have
something screwy with my maze M's
so there's not really that much of a
suggestion from M
there get this up for
Neptune and we'll just see if we can do
a little bit on e3b potentially play
I see so I didn't really do anything
over
here I I guess we're fine to do stuff on
this Branch
right
experience reward minus mean by standard
deviation plus one eus
6 right right right okay so I did some
initial list up on this I remember
now yeah I remember this now
there we
are and
SLE score is not
present yet it will
be so if I just run this as
is you
[Music]
see no improvement at
all .4 these are reasonable looking
hypers and we just get no
reward
whatsoever
Flatline we'll let this run for I don't
know like a little longer just to
see but it's kind of funny that this
literally will never find the
goal I should probably control for
random seed
to be
fair there are probably maps for which
it does find the goal
right but if we're just going to do like
initial
cursory
stuff count space should make it solve
just about any map
here so e3b is an approximation to count
spaced I tried count spaced and it
worked very very
well in fact I think I might have even
even left that code into the grid I
might have left that code in the grid so
maybe we try that next hang
on
red let's kill this because it's hit 50
are so I'm going to run this exact same
thing
I'd also like to know why my restream is
not
stats there we go it's got auto logged
out
I'm kind of wondering about the seed
here
though well let's see if this does
anything
first is it going to full solve it
though or is it going to get
that that's pretty weird the way that
this is
curved no it does figure it out there it
is that's a full
solve so it had a little bit of a weird
start to it but counts full solves
there you go so counts full
solves so
e3b should full solve if it is
approximating counts and doing it
correctly we'll double check seed we'll
double check a bunch of other things e3b
should full solve
if the algorithm is worth its uh worth
its solt
right okay so we
rebuild just rebuild this
grid
oops use e
this and we'll let it uh we'll let it
run for a little bit
here and we'll see if uh e3b actually
does something
here and then we can rerun this we
potentially as
well I don't like it collapsing it's not
fully collapsed like Po is
though still gets a little bit of
reward we'll see if it figures anything
out
right 3B
Norm let's this get used
for w oh this is for the running mean
okay
anymore to be fair I also know that
counts was pretty sensitive to um reward
magnitude already do the root canals
later in the week that was
yesterday so I had one procedure for
that and then I have to go back tomorrow
for like probably four hours worth of
crown
fitting um and then I have to go and
they're an hour away and then I have to
go back yet again probably a few days
after that to actually once they've made
the crown to actually put it
on and I also have unrelated other
doctor stuff to do tomorrow so yeah this
week kind of just sucks this week is
like I don't have much time to do much
of
anything
um I managed to at least get a haircut
but that's about
I knocked out a bunch of dental
stuff it's good to get it all done yeah
well I mean the thing that would have
been way better is if I just you know
bothered to
actually uh get like figure out how to
have a stable like stable consistent
dentist appointments while I was
traveling
a bunch during my
PhD um so I wouldn't have had this that
would have been better
but we'll make
do I mean the thing that sucked in
particular was just the first dentist I
went to here in Florida like really
screwed up my teeth it just it was just
absolute idiot
so this one doesn't help pretty busy
making still progress feaking 3D got
freak cam working which helped me figure
out oh they we're doing some stuff yep
that is
good I left you a mess of garbage
code I left you a absolute mess of just
garbage garbage code I
aware
so I basically wanted to like I want
like I had a spare bit of time uh
towards the end of the week I figured I
would try to get as much done I could do
in about two-ish work days so I wanted
to at least get the stuff in place there
for you to be able to fiddle with
Thruster uh yeah but you can do it in
you could do it either way I I think it
would be better to just do it all in 3D
because then you won't end up with
camera
problems like otherwise you're going to
end up with perspective problems with
different cameras so what I tried to do
with the laser which I don't know if you
saw is I tried to make the laser just a
line for the um the sniper I'd suggest
you do that just make it a
line so it's like a thin
thing and then maybe put a little Point
light wherever it hits the wall so you
know you can see where it's aiming on a
wall that might be cool but I don't
think the walls are affected by the
lighting at the moment I tried that it
didn't look
good I mean you did a ton of work on the
uh the game I figured I'd at least put
in some effort on the visuals it is
really important when you have like a
truly good and complex environment that
it looks the part it is
important also I got so I can try that
at some point I got this so I do have a
controller to try it with now hopefully
works on
Linux I will blame you if uh Elden ring
happens to make its way into my steam
downloads drone lighting was disabled
didn't realize sud the lighting was is
in the grid
shaders yeah I uh I think it looks
better if you just have the projectile
lights
on you could even probably disable a lot
of the dynamic lighting it like getting
real Bloom working on the projectiles
would do a lot of that for
you um the only thing that's kind of
cool is like it sort of makes like a
muzzle flare type effect especially with
like the shotgun or whatever where
they're all stacked
up I don't know
controller so this stuff doesn't work at
all
001 this
instead see if there's any version of
e3b that does
okay I got e3b to do
something I got e3b to do
something now the question is is this
seed
specific or is this consist and
replicable we run it again think what I
do is once I get the graphics polished
and everything's working in 3D add a
camera toggle like you said but make the
default Dynamic cam with medium foot
field of view so like the original game
right the other modes will be Ortho cam
basically
2D yeah I think you could just make it
so that the play mode looks like the
original game right where it's like a
top down um 3D cam like that and then
you can just make the like the spectator
mode right the spectator mode can be the
iso cam
um yeah I think that's fine
I think that the default though should
be
whatever you might want to build
different for like the website versus
for local like the default should be
whatever looks
cooler for uh for the
demo so if you get the top down cam to
look cooler that's fine
but I think that should be the goal is
just like the Demo's got to look
cool
H okay so this is a problem because the
seem's not
replicable default will be dynamic cam
like in retr yeah that's good
okay I mean you would think here
that what if we go back to
PCG we go back
to num
default for web will be dynamic cam well
if that looks cooler then sure right
I think it's just uh I think it's map
seed specific so I don't know if it's
e3b actually doing the thing or
not I'm trying something here
like it was on to something for a second
there very fiddly
I think it's worth re running a new
sweep at
least it's interesting because it's like
it's keeping some success
rate right but it's not fully
there's also the
e3b Lambda or
whatever needs to be tuned
there might be a little potential in
this let's go add the Lambda coefficient
one
this we'll do a one like that maybe
e3b
Lambda can go from it
10 B is going to
be
it I hate the auto correct
sometimes I wish I could disable
multi-line completes like that cuz
they're just stupid
all right so these are some nice
coefficients I'd
say and I think we also want to turn off
this
neeling SP Cuda
uh everything else can stay as
this use e3b as
true that is
set and uh yeah everything
else kind of just do
don't learn vstd per
LM oh yeah that works right hang
sessions Place
rebuild and then uh we can run that
warnings and we'll see maybe there is
something to e3b
probably needs the
token let's get
so that should learn some
stuff we'll see if any of these
experiments
work and then we'll also see you know if
e3b helps if e3b doesn't
help or what's going
okay gold in here
next stuff
um I would like to do something with the
diversity is all you
need
paper I couldn't get it to do much on
breakout I think where's what does an
end where you would expect that to
do to do something
snake I don't know if it's going to give
us
much I think we can try
it may as well
now that could be
cool yeah it's on its own Branch though
right
I'm thinking we do a couple experiments
on this and then I'm going to need to
get some
see but ideally we have uh experiments
running so that when I get back it will
be stuff with that code observations got
unexpected
keyword ah I
see yeah so you need to add
in the encoder and then the
how bad is it if I just use the default
model for snake I think it's pretty bad
right all right let's grab this
yeah I think that this is a decent one
because like there's actually some hope
of it doing something and it's
multi-agent and we have a problem where
I think this could help I think this
will just be very nice to have in
general see
so we also need this
it's a little bit of a pain to integrate
I think
because
really this Vector
so we'll
do and then this will just be out
channels here to Hidden
size and now
here code
observations
um ooh
yeah that's a little fiddly isn't
it you have to do
this
dot you're
hidden it's going to be.
network
oops
Network
obervations yeah and then you get a
concatenation here and it's di all you
need Z
see okay that's good
now you also put this
into you do forward and Ford train I
think I use these now don't
I for
TR for TR for TR for TR for
yeah so right here this needs to take in
for train it needs to take Z and for it
needs to take
channels and this is just hacky research
dep code R since
like okay so this is
shape encoder out
40 skills am I not passing the number of
skills to
this
plus skills yeah I guess I'm not passing
the init to this
d
i a y n
oh you can't because you do that's
annoying as
hell okay so I actually do have to
figure out then
happening
eight
okay what I do
channels passed the
wrong oh hang on I think I just passed
the
wrong pass the wrong thing in
runs the
train yeah but look at this di look at
this
loss this loss term of
zero is very sketchy to me
like I don't think if we run this we're
going to see agents playing the game in
a way that's meaningfully different from
each
other oh also this is the dumb version
of snake
difference does this train at 3.9
million steps per
second that's funny as as hell and it's
still all in the
something's weird with it being at uh
3.9 million I think that's too
high 4 million yeah there's something
wrong I think it's too high
oops maybe let me
see num
M's num
M something's wrong
there for sure something's wrong there
was this just a massive number of M's
hang
on
snakes shouldn't it just be
like what was it
hey 1.8k on puffer very nice look at
that good
growth
turn two and
two these are all the same 200
that there we go it just wrong number of
Ms okay
I do seem to remember it performing
better than
oh this is the same as
before
interesting I mean that really does not
perform
great trains real fast
though
28 okay and if I can I run this
change the
default false to true
now you have to
do the Z term don't you
let's try this first this one doesn't
have
Z oh it doesn't have an RNN on it that's
why it's
fast it's
crazy lstm
forward oh I don't know why this doesn't
have an RNN on
it it should just have it should have an
RNN on it right here
right not
unpack yeah there's something
um I can just change that to none and
none
miss how's this how's this happening
here this should
work I'm going to have to fiddle with
this in a bit
um where' it go so I'm getting really
hungry um I think what we're going to do
we're real quick just make sure that
these runs are actually
going and
do tags
group one's
here yeah so I these all runs are like
these are all doing roughly the same
here
um okay I'm going to go get some food
I'm going to go do a couple things and
then I'm going to come back and we'll do
some more Dev on this and see if we can
get this working or e3b working or some
sort of exploration working um thanks
for tuning in po. for all the things
Star join Discord X all that we'll be
back in a bit